[Musique]
on est au dessus 17 juillet
montre que les français se réveillent et
se lève il serait non pas insulter d'une
espèce de dengue qui est à la tête de
l'état s'est permis d'abord il prend
pour orduriers que dix missions
l'apartheid contre son propre première
dans les gendarmes il est français
[Musique]
notre président est en train de monter
les bug superphone vacciner contre les
personnes non vaccinées et ça c'est pas
digne d'un président de la république et
propos qu'il a tenus récemment sont
totalement
choquant il m'a insulté au niveau haut
niveau on peut me dire
citoyenneté donc c'est très grave à mes
amis lieu je trouve
[Musique]
c'est